when we were kids
uh i don't know if you fooled around
with m80s and you'd blow up an m80 and
like oh [ __ ] that's pretty cool and you
would try to put the m80 in this thing
you would try to put it underground ac
it would blow up anything would happen
yeah you would do all this stuff with
m80s and then every once in a while one
of the guys would bring something
that was bigger than an m80 and you
thought the reaction to the m80 was
going to be like an median you know what
an m80 does right right and you put the
other one that was a bigger thing more
powerful dynamiting like holy [ __ ] we
were not ready for this right and some
people could get hurt
how do we even test super emps like i
know north korea uh has apparently you
said north korea has tested super emp's
but
aren't super emp's almost one of those
things here i see that article right
there north korea tested a super emp
weapon that could potentially wipe out
nearly the entire united us population
so here's my question how the hell do
you know
how do you know that could wipe out the
entire u.s population and how do you not
know that maybe it's
either worse or weaker than what you
think this is like one of those things
that's tough to test you know you can
test it in one region that can affect a
lot of different people so how do we
really know the
true
negative
impact of emp how bad it could be how
big it could be or how small it could be
oh i think we have lots of uh
of evidence
uh you know during the early 1960s for
example uh when we did the
test over johnson island in fact we
didn't even know about the emp
phenomenology we just knew that the
russians knew about something
that some phenomena was happening
because they were conducting a series of
tests over kazakhstan
they were detonating nuclear weapons
varying yield including very small ones
and very big ones in outer space over
over their own territory over kazakhstan
which was an inhabited part of russia
kazakh stands in an enormous area about
the size of france
and and so we decided and they were
breaking the
uh there had been a an agreement to not
do
atmospheric testing anymore and they
were breaking the agreement this thing
was considered so important for them to
do that and so we did a test over
johnston island and
lit off a nuclear weapon in outer space
and uh it basically knocked out the
lights in hawaii
caused automobiles to fail knocked out
radio transmission stations and things
like and hawaii was 1500 kilometers away
it was just on the very edge of the
field where the field is weakest and so
we could see that that had uh you know
profound effects
and we have built emp simulators
after we stopped atmospheric nuclear
testing and exo-atmosphere because this
is actually being tested in outer space
when when you detonate the weapon it's
not in the atmosphere but we have these
uh
emp simulators so we can put all kinds
of electronics the commission on which i
served is the last
or uh really concerted effort where we
did
the broadest and most in-depth analysis
of the effects of emp on modern
electronic systems by putting all kinds
of things into into simulators and
frying them
you know because we know what the emp
fields will look like you can calculate
it from the gamma-ray output of a
nuclear warhead it's called the compton
effect you know the gamma rays will will
come out of the bomb they'll knock
electrons off of atoms and the high
atmosphere the electrons will spin at
the speed of light following the earth's
magnetic field to the horizon and that's
what makes the emp and it basically
creates this
this pulse
that's like a super energetic radar wave
or radio wave
you know for a non for a normal nuclear
weapon it's 50 000 volts per meter that
means for every meter of of dimension of
the target it gets 50 000 volts injected
into it so uh you know the the the wires
on this
thing here probably are half a meter so
this thing would get 25 000 volts
injected into it at the speed of light
i'm sure it's not designed to survive
that you know
if you had an automobile that was uh you
know typical automobile might be four
four meters long so that's four times 50
000 so 200 000 volts injected into the
car's electronics at the speed of light
a super emp weapon can generate
twice that or more than twice that and
so you're talking about extraordinarily
powerful fields
our electronic civilization you were i'm
answering your question in my
long-winded way about how do we know
well we know because our electronic
civilization is pretty much
almost everything is designed to operate
on 120 volts or less
you know that personal that computer
sitting in front of you is probably
operates on on 25 volts you know it's uh
it steps the power down from the but the
outlets
in this in this area put out 120 volts
okay
so things that are designed to operate
on 120 volts almost certainly are not
going to survive when you inject 50 000
100 000 200 000 volts at the speed of
light into them and we know they don't
survive because we have simulated that
for many decades you know both the
department of defense and the last the
commission on which i served we weren't
just a paper commission you know we were
about actually testing modern
electronics to see were the electronics
vulnerable we knew they would be
vulnerable but one of the questions we
wanted to know is are they getting more
vulnerable and and they are because
microchip technology you know which is
responsible for the great prosperity and
efficiency of our modern electronic
civilization every decade
it gets 10 times faster operates on 10
times lower voltages okay but that also
makes them every decade about 10 times
more vulnerable so we're going in the
direction of greater and greater
vulnerability and then and then
we have other things that we can look at
what happens when the lights go out for
example in hurricanes or tornadoes or
ice storms what happens to society we
have lots of data to show that
24 hours after lights go out
about when people miss their third meal
you know the glue that holds society
together starts coming unglued and uh
and uh you know when the society just
starts very quickly disintegrating so we
do have a lot of data it's not just
theoretical we have uh you know we can
test this stuff through simulators we
have seen it tested and in the nuclear
detonations of the past
and we have real world experience every
year from hurricanes hurricane sandy
hurricane katrina you go back and you
look at what happens to society and this
is just a small scale thing when you
have these blackouts that affect regions
and they're only temporary imagine uh if
you had you know a phenomena that would
black out all of north america for a
year
that's how we uh you know we tried hard
to think how do you keep 330 million
people alive
for a year with no electricity which
means
no water
no food the food supply we only have
enough food in this country to feed 330
million people for 30 days in the big
regional food warehouses and it will
immediately begin to spoil when the
temperature control systems and
refrigerators and stuff stop receiving
electricity you can't get the food
to the grocery stores you know because
the trucks and transport vehicles would
be paralyzed uh you know there's only
enough food in a grocery store at normal
consumption rates to feed the local
population for two or three days how do
you keep 330 million people alive for a
year with no food no water
you know no organized government you
can't i mean we we tried very hard to
come up with ways of doing it including
mobilizing the army to air drop food
supplies into the cities you know meals
are ready to eat we have you know a
billion meals ready it's not enough
and uh it's not practical that's why our
recommendation was you know we can't
afford to take an emp head and expect to
survive we've got to harden our critical
infrastructures protect the electric
grid so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]
you